سلمى كيف هو الوضع في اليوم التالي لقصف
مستشفى المعمداني في غزه اليوم التالي هو
يوم احصاء الضحايا بدايه الضحايا 500 شهيد
حتى الان جراء هذا الاستهداف الاسرائيلي
للمستشفى وهذه الحصيله هي مرجحه للزياده
لان الاعداد اعداد الشهداء نتيجه هذا
الاستهداف وهذا القصف للمستشفى لازال جاري
العمل على جمعهم من المستشفيات الاخرى
بالاضافه لعامل اخر وهذا عامل جدا يعني
صادم و سيء جدا بان هناك اشخاص هم اشلاء
لا يعرفون ه الاشلاء من هم اصحابها ويجري
الان تجميعها في كل الاحوال كل ذلك يجري
على وقع تاكيدات من قبل السلطات الحكوميه
في قطاع غزه وزاره الصحه في قطاع غزه
وايضا المعطيات الموثقه من فيديوهات رصدت
لحظه القصف بان ما جرى هو قصف اسرائيلي
ويستدل عليه بدلائل عده ان كان من طريقه
الاستهداف صوت الاستهداف صوت القصف الكتله
الناريه اللهب التي خرجت وايضا التحذيرات
عن طريق اطلاق قذائف استهدفت هذا المستشفى
من قبل الجانب الاسرائيلي الذي طالب
المستشفى وا الطاقم فيه بمغادرته وحذرهم
عن طريق استهداف مباشر بقنابل طالت هذا
المستشفى في كل الاحوال هذا ما جرى ولكن
بطبيعه الحال الروايه الاسرائيليه تحاول
التضليل وهذا كان هو محور ما جرى منذ هذا
ما حدث في الاستهداف حيث خرجت اسرائيل
وتبنت هذه العمليه على منصه اكس ومن ثم
انسحبت عن هذه الروايه وقامت بالغاء مثل
هذه التغريدات المتعلقه بهذا الاستهداف
بسبب شناعه ما جرى والعدد الكبير وكان
هناك ايضا فيديوهات ادعت بانها للحظه ما
جرى وجرى ايضا سحب هذه الفيديوهات لياتي
الناطق باسم جيش الاحتلال اليوم في مؤتمر
صحفي ويحاول ان يدعم هذه الروا ويقول بان
حماس او الجهاد الاسلامي هي من استهدفت
هذا المستشفى في القطاع على كل كل ذلك
ياتي في اطار ايضا زياره يقوم بها بايدن
حيث وصل اليوم الى تل ابيب وكان من
المفترض ان ينتقل من واشنطن الى عمان ولكن
بعد هذه المجزره جرى الغاء القمه الرباعيه
في عمان وتوجه نتيجه لذلك بايدن مباشره
الى تل ابيب واجتمع برئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو ليتبنى الروايه الاسرائيليه على
الملا ويقول بانه يبدو بان ما جرى هو حدث
نتيجه الجانب الاخر ولستم انتم
الاسرائيليين من قمتم به بهذه السرعه وهذا
الوضوح وهذه الكلمات تحدث جو بايدن الرئيس
الامريكي
مخاطبا الجمهور من تلبي